[Music]
all right you know what they say about
rainy days on such celebrations it's
really fantastic luck for the future so
welcome welcome everyone to this great
moment of celebration some of you have
been with us for three semesters some
for three years and some and some for
more some of you have left and come back
and today is the day all of you have
been working so hard for let's hear a
big cheer to this moment and a huge
congratulations
[Applause]
relish this moment for we are gathered
here to celebrate all of you and your
achievement that of completing your
masters or PhD degree in one of the many
disciplines of the built environment and
so I wanted to take this opportunity to
especially thank your family and friends
many of whom have come a very long way
to build it with you and with us today
even from here I can feel a sense of the
pride and Happiness emanating from where
they are standing and it's quite
uplifting thank you all for being with
us
[Applause]
I also wanted to thank the program
directors the faculty and the
administrative deans who are sitting up
here with me as well as those who are
dispersed in the audience and then and
who in ways big and small and have
enabled this day to happen we are all
collectively very proud and happy and as
always with graduation lifted by a sense
not of an end but of the beautiful
beginning that of many long rich and
diverse journeys that are ready to
launch today today is also special not
only because we GISA have taken over a
fairly big chunk of the Morningside
campus which certainly gives me great
pleasure but because that is the one day
in the year when the school is actually
entirely visible to itself and to others
we are so used to operating in the
density of Abraham which let's face it
really stands as the ultimate
confirmation that architecture as the
Russian constructivist once put forth
can really act as a social condenser
that inherently produces the kind of
endless creative spark fresh energy and
meaningful exchanges we love the school
for that especially it's a special
moment of taking stock of our sheer
physical scale is also one in which we
register the presence and richness of
all of the ideas that you have enabled
in your time here but beyond simply
acknowledging the extent of the school
and the reach breadth and diversity of
the ideas it represents it is also
important to note what this scale
suggests that together we represent all
of the disciplines of the built
environment architecture urban design
urban planning historic preservation
critical and curatorial practices as
well as real estate development
you know who makes the most noise in the
school and together I believe we can
shape the built environment in ways we
can not know yet but we can aspire to
working together to turn all of your
ideas into reality whether you are
graduating with an architecture urban
design urban planning or historic
preservation degree or whether you have
devoted the past semesters of your life
to expanding practice Vito cccp program
or reimagining real estate development
and its potential to shape architecture
and cities in new ways the knowledge and
skills you have acquired as well as the
inquiries you have engaged in an
advanced are entirely intertwined today
you graduate as one school as a
testimony to the interconnectedness of
all of those disciplines and the
critical importance of reconnecting them
not only inside the academic walls but
more importantly outside in the world
we're thinking relationally across
cities cultures and contexts and
engaging the built environment across
all of its scales spatial as well as
temporal has never been more urgent and
we're continually and collaboration
across our disciplines as well as
expansion contamination and hybridity of
our practices has never been more
productive in the formation of new
knowledge and new possibilities for
engagement and so today marks this first
transitional step and I hope you will
hold this moment in your memory not only
for its joy but also for its power of
standing here all together because this
is what we do because this is what we do
at graduation and this is what
graduation is every year we reenact to
this moment of transition as a rite of
passage a passage from inside the walls
of academia to the outside and the
realities of the world this moment of
transition is in some ways embodied by
this site where you find ourselves
in because we are standing symbolically
within the crosshairs of two axes the
low library Butler Hall axes of
knowledge with alma mater somewhere
behind us
looking down been ability at us and the
kind of exit to egress axis which
connects Broadway to answer them and
takes you to the city beyond these gates
but while this rite of passage is
reenacted every year with all the
staying symbolism and power full sense
of procession that this McKim Mead and
white urban campus still constructs for
us it is also completely different every
year and for every generation every year
it is experienced magically with the
same freshness optimism and pride and
with the knowledge that inside and
outside inextricable intertwining and
constant transformation of one another
can only render the meaning of this day
at once known and unknown the same but
also completely different unique and
specific to you and to this time we are
in so what do you take with you and what
you leave behind today as we transition
from inside to outside firstly and most
importantly maybe are the friendships
that you have made and that you will
carry with you for many years to come
there are very few moments in life when
it seems like you are suspended in time
able to focus entirely on something with
unbelievable intensity and utter
disregard for any mundane interruption
you know the laundry eating sleeping the
time you spend together is this kind of
time it is absolute uncompromised fresh
idealist at once completely devouring
and fulfilling nothing else exists but
your work your ideas your passions and
the friends you share those with those
bonds are some of the most inspired and
the most resilient cherish them for
these friends and friendships will be
there for you
you seek to find them there are also
your teachers and the faculty who
engaged in ideas with you and offer
guidance for your own work information
as an architect and designer a planner a
curator or president a preservationist
or developer those bombs are also unique
and with a staying power one always
remembers the faculty who inspired them
or those with whom they disagreed with
vociferously stay in touch for your
teachers or mentors who will be there
for you I know it sounds like a cliche
but believe me it's almost always true
just an example recently I received an
email it said you may not remember that
you taught me studio some years back you
let me go to Morocco to present a mud
house I had just built the week before
final reviews that was a bad idea
even though my project suffered for it I
always appreciated your openness to let
me explore professionally and
internationally at that time it's true I
did not remember the student in the
abstract but his reaching out
immediately brought him back to my mind
and I was delighted to meet him and
learn how well he was doing so do stay
in touch then there are the ideas about
architecture and cities about the
environment and about buildings but also
about what makes a community at a time
of increasing intolerance and
radicalization a time of violence
folding back onto notions of identity
that are not engaged towards new
knowledge the broadening of
understandings and perspectives or the
richness of encounters but rather and
listed to limit exclude and divide we
stand as a community formed not because
of our sameness but because of our
differences it is because of those
differences of backgrounds and interests
and the diversity of positions and
experiences they represent that we are
gathered here coming together around
ideas which we embrace and debate
together always in a spirit
openness respect and intellectual
generosity I have liked many of you love
the many places I lived in but I believe
the richness of encounters that exists
on this campus and our school is unique
carry this experience with you with all
the curiosity respect and continued
desire to look at everything from both
inside and outside as you are in this
moment and you will find yourself at
home wherever you go so what you leave
behind well you leave us the present to
discover your own way of rereading the
past and projecting the future
in 1923 reflecting on this relationship
of past to future as seen through the
transfer of knowledge across generations
writer and artist Khalil Gibran wrote in
his poem quote on children the following
your children are not your children they
are the sons and daughters of life's
longing for itself they come through you
but not from you and though they are
with you yet they belong not to you you
may give them your love but not your
thoughts for they have their own
thoughts you may house their bodies but
not their souls for their souls dwell in
the house of tomorrow which you cannot
visit not even in your dreams you may
strive to be like them but seek not to
make them like you for life goes not
backward nor terry's with yesterday you
are the boughs from which your children
as living arrows are sent forth you are
the future a future we cannot know but
that we can together aspire to and that
you will shape at a time when our
present moment is filled with challenges
the future must be hopeful for all of
the challenges facing the world today
are intimately connected to the built
environment they represent unprecedented
opportunities to reimagine how we live
what we do how we organize ourselves how
we exchange how we move what we share
and how we recast a relationship to each
other to the planet and to other species
as Evan sharp noted the founder of
Pinterest and our honoree at the Alumni
forum a couple of weeks ago today we
have developed endless technology but
where are the ideas the critical and
engage ideas about design and cities
about infrastructure and density about
form program typology aesthetics meaning
even about urban ecology about once what
constitute a critical practice for the
future about equitable and sustainable
development and about preservation of
tangible and intangible heritage --is
that can either bind us or unable a more
progressive future I have no doubt that
you will be the bearer of those ideas
and only wish you carry the freshness
irreverence imagination and idealism
with you with which you approach every
day of your time here out there it will
not be easy nor will it be linear nor
will it be expected or planned life or
at least a small part that we control is
like the design process itself you have
ideas and aspirations you imagine
something and think you understand it a
certain way you have a set of references
an archive of some sort you leave all of
it together and engage you make a
decision this decision safe shapes this
project that is your practice your
scholarship your life in a certain way
which in turn shapes you as you get
ready to take another turn sometimes it
will be more about work and sometimes
about life and sometimes it will be
miraculously about both at the same time
but all along you are learning
encountering new ideas people and places
and new possibilities and there are so
many more possibilities today to shape
practice and scholarship and new ways
there are so many more ingredients to
consider when engaging architecture so
many spaces professional and academics
that have seen critical and engaged
design thinking and
infiltrate them more than ever cities
the object of planning preservation and
real estate forces have become not only
places of a put opportunity as a global
network of connected flows that have
also emerged as the scale of
interconnected transnational engagement
and action towards climate change social
justice inclusion and progressive
thinking this is not to say that our
work and focus lies in the forming of
buildings or cities as isolated islands
bubbles whether real or virtual but
rather that it should strive to move
beyond the bubbles it often finds itself
in and designed instead a way out of
them we have the privileged ability to
draw vectors that connect rather than
divide and the skill expertise and I
hope desire and will to reimagine the
relationship between building cities and
the infrastructures then enable them to
render the invisible visible and to
create new context for engagement and
for action whether in the form of design
or in the form of a critical
representation of what was what is and
what could be your time at the school
offers a glimpse of those possibilities
it never aspired to transmit knowledge
in a monolithic or authoritative way to
provide stable answers or reductive
solutions rather we aspire to create an
intellectual context for your own work
and positions and invitation for your
own recasting of questions and problems
and to equip you with the skills to open
up new possibilities and the confidence
to shape your own future and thus to
shape the future of the field what and
how you shape our extended field will in
turn inform what and how we teach in
here this relationship is a construct
built to enable both sides to change
together and you are the agent of this
change a few last words before parting
enjoy yourself
take pleasure in what you're doing give
it everything you have and always
remember the passion and drive of your
days here continue to believe that
nothing is impossible bring freshness
and boldness to your work and braise the
delicate combination of humility and
irreverence continue to learn and be
curious to listen and observe it takes
an excruciatingly ly long time to become
good at what you do and what you love
maybe you are focusing for some time on
one aspect you want to become better at
or on an experience you want to dig
deeper and/or and maybe you are already
engaged in exactly what you have always
dreamed you would you building what you
imagined you would or contributing
thinking and action in the most
fulfilling ways or in it maybe you're
just following your instincts letting
yourself drift for a while take the time
to do all of those things fully in many
ways your fleeting experience here at
Columbia's jisub isn't only about
becoming a professional it is a capsule
of experiences and of moments you will
on archive at key crossroads in your
life to remind you of what may be most
passionate as you continue to be invited
and repeatedly confronted to making new
choices take risks work hard they'll
often try again and so today is not an
end but actually the beginning of an
incredible adventure your adventure
congratulations everyone
[Applause]
and now I will invite the program
directors to compare the degrees first
the holiday professor for the Master of
Science and real estate and development
patrice Darrington and I invite the
milking professor Cade archers to give
up the awards
Thank You Dean andreas vidi Govans
Advani
[Applause]
June base on ro doll ajami risk
recipient of the Hank fell
entrepreneurial award for the students
at best embodies professor emeritus Hank
fells entrepreneurial spirit met our top
Martin Alvaro
[Applause]
super hard and soon while Ramsay
[Music]
then form of all Michael beer Alastair
George Foucault Joseph beyond Beuys
Edward Christopher burns recipient of
the real estate development Service
Award for participation and leadership
within the real estate development
program and Lexus Jennifer Campbell
always it seemed off I see severe Victor
wing Liu Chang will pass on our Chandra
[Applause]
King we Chang recipient of a real estate
development Service Award for
participation and leadership within the
re D program Christina
Chow also recipient of an re D Service
Award for participation and leadership
within the program Ravi doe chart on our
ways recipient of a scholastic
performance award for high academic
attainment in the re D program Jo Chen
yucky ching-ching-ching
Michael John Clark
Jonathan Christopher Cobb a recipient of
the scholastic performance award for
high academic attainment in the re D
program Brandon Scott cook Joseph Saba
[Applause]
[Music]
bruno de las tres her on Maria Beatriz
PR Benjamin Adam Epstein Richard
Esquivel Brian Fatah
but Sir Andrew truckers Fitzpatrick
Gabriele Bernard Fort Robert Daniel
Franco TR Ishita
mohandro Scala sama Mahmud gala
[Applause]
Nicole Catherine gaeda Adrian Glasscock
jo Chong go li chen's go Thomas Matthew
Gray
d sharp Grover Nicholas Russell grew a
young can do up
Madalyn Murray malobi
hips elect province irani Edward
Harrison Horowitz James Ross Horton
recipient of the William Kinney fellows
prize for travel and study abroad for
the proposal the northern transition
leggings for Cato to Tokyo with
Shinkansen also for Jaime Walton a cure
Award for the Advancement of
transdisciplinary research in urban
development half of Ron who
[Applause]
Patrick Cole Hudson recipient recipient
of a cure award for the transistor
pollen research in urban development
I need Rudy Jane
mark Elle's James
[Applause]
myeongsu a Jamie Jiang Shi Jin
Siobhan from Germany
Jana Caravelle Aki Sita
Sandeep carnival seung-heon Kim
[Applause]
ah Rishon kirshen blood William
Christopher Kearney armed Heyman law
[Applause]
Erico sleeve
Minjae Lee recipient of a William Keaney
fellows prize the topic being when
drones are flying the future of urban
infrastructure a real-estate value and
an irrepressibly enthusiastic member of
the class Patrick Lee Patrick is a dual
degree in the Master of Science in urban
planning also the recipient the
recipient of the annual instance re the
American Institute of Certified planners
Alex standing Student Award for
outstanding attainment is a study of
urban planning
she unchanged Lee when she means she
also easy
[Applause]
yes yang li you Shaylee
[Music]
[Applause]
Edison J when Lynn when and wrongly land
shyam Lou laning Liu Ying 0 John William
Leon parents Richard Milan Abdullah am
RH Marathi recipients of the scholastic
performance award the high academic
attainment in the re D program
[Applause]
Amanda Jane Moses Alexis ruler Pelerin
winner of the shark tower competition
but he's always you've got his trophy
Alexander's Noah Michael
[Music]
Aikido narcos Chinese Jason Nick
[Applause]
Samuel Michael of ketchup Emerick Paul
Patterson Brett Victor price
Matthew prop Thomas a
Rock'em all recipient of a William Keene
fellows fries the topic being the
northern transition linking Hokkaido to
Tokyo which enchancia Jorge Luis Rica
Delhi Samantha Kaitlyn Richard maybe
Karolina Rojas aha rock Rudy Yanni
Maria Rosenfeld who's Hussein Tarek
amazi Edward Santa Paul shabby chalk
[Music]
[Applause]
David Matthew Silva Prateek Singh hey UK
Sean
[Applause]
heyyyyy tongue mert mert Atari Patrick
Hamilton Taylor see your tongue
gr send Jerry you keychain Ben Edmund
will be bothered by China boot fan
Archie on wrong
so that's John Daniel Berger Carl
William Walker
Shiro Wang Yu ting Wang then happens and
ends when Andrew Graham Watson Bridget
browning Real Talk Andrew David Wright
[Applause]
Jing Zi Rui
launching shado Katie Yael wanting a
take Dae Jung Eun Jo minsang Sue Ellen
jo and a meal zuikou recipient of a real
estate development service award for the
dissipation for leadership in the re G
program and the best real estate
development study trip in the history
thank you
and now for the master sirens and
historic preservation calling the
director professor Jorge with zero Pylos
and professor pitch Chekov rami
for the awards so exciting Tania alam
recipient of a historic preservation
faculty Award for outstanding thesis the
evolution of american historic color
palettes advisor marriage' Blonsky
[Applause]
Jessica Elizabeth bets recipient of a
historic preservation faculty Award for
outstanding thesis the influence of
glass transition temperatures on the
performance of acrylic thermal plastic
adhesive advisors George wheeler
[Applause]
Elizabeth Lawrence Canon Myesha Jalad
recipient of a historic preservation
faculty Award for outstanding thesis
Beirut civil war hotel district
preserving the world's first high-rise
turbine battlefield adviser Jorge Terra
pylos and the peer to peer award in
recognition of outstanding service to
her classmates faculty in school
[Applause]
Cheng Miao recipient of a William Kinney
fellows prize for travel and study
abroad for the proposal modern
adaptations of vernacular architecture
case study of architects and non
architects practice in Vietnam Sarah
Nicole Megas Nicole Marie Mozilla
[Applause]
Alexander Paul Ray
Sarah redden Cameron marine Robertson
dual degree with Master of Science in
urban planning recipient of the GSA PP
Service Award in recognition of willing
service to the school and who gives
promise of real professional merit
through attitude and character
Alison Leah cymryd Andrea Nicole sports
ax Teresa and Spears they Teng Stacy
Lynn Tom chick katrina
lee Verbitsky recipient of a William
Kenny fellows prize for the conservation
and management of the Berlin Wall
concrete panels
Laura Allen wins Weinstein recipient of
a historic preservation faculty Award
for outstanding thesis the progression
of historic preservation in Miami Beach
and the challenges of sea-level rise
advisor Carol Clarke
[Applause]
mengjie Zhong please Ungh recipient of a
historic preservation faculty Award for
outstanding pieces urban preservation in
China the survival of an idea despite
political repression 1952 1982 adviser
Jorge Otero pylos congratulations his
her preservation class of 2017
and now for the master science and urban
planning I'm calling director professor
vaping who and professor Bob Beauregard
for the awards shall be a lower rate
[Applause]
Vincent a Oswaldo Arellano Ming Bastian
Jessica Joanna crew Lombardo Escalante
recipient of the William Kenan fellows
price for travel and study abroad for
the proposal the right to livelihood
housing and under housing in India ETL
Fung
[Applause]
James Asha gherkin Stephen get
Christopher Daniel Gil Marino SHINee's
Kathy Ling Wong John Crispin cervix
Jackson recipient of a William Coonan
fellows prize the right to livelihood I
think we gotta run title Chris Tristan
and the planning methodology award cool
roofs program as municipal policy and a
share zone 5 climates advisor qian taj
mahai for master's thesis that best
applies a critical planning methodology
Mira Kahn on genichi may Lagos sorry
Neha Krishnan on Ponce only Jose
Gabrielle llama tree Palma recipient of
the William Kenan fellows price contra
narrative spaces and other graphic study
of Bohol semana and the urban planning
program award for high academic
attainment Dorothy Brayton McCausland
recipient of the planning practice award
exploring expertise rather than planners
and the flood adaptation industry
advisor liam eiffel inform a thesis that
directly engages the practice of
planning and the New York Chapter of the
American Planning Association award for
academic excellence and leadership in
urban planning Richard Charles montage
Leo Madeline McCrory
[Music]
Joseph byron's Mackenzie Sarah Mir Bobby
recipient of a william cannon fellows
price men street and american from peace
and the urban planning student here to
appear award in recognition of
outstanding service to classmates
faculty and school mathias Kelsey
Atticus Neil Lauren Rhea OC Kritika
praha Camryn brendan new robinson lea
Cernan recipient of the child's abran
thesis award land use and sea level rise
vulnerability in New York City
addressing environmental justice through
zoning advisor waving Wu for thesis that
best exemplifies a commitment to social
justice
Charl Carol Stuart loosen
Jacqueline Danielle seung-wu
Evan Renick sweet mom y'all Wang means
will Wang Li Na in tailor Charles young
[Applause]
Maryann's Abba you hobby in judo
congratulations an urban planning class
of 2017
and now for the master of science and
critical care toriel and conceptual
practices the co-director Felicity Scott
and Mark Matsuda for the awards Daniel
Cooper Chloe Elizabeth English Russia
key recipients of a William Kinney
fellows prize for travel and study
abroad for the proposal surveillance of
the technological sublime Jochum Hakone
recipient of a William Kinney fellows
prize for surveillance soundscapes 1928
to 1937 and slowed down a bit then and
the cccp thesis award for new games
countercultural spaces of play 1973 to
1985 advisor Felicity Scott for the CSIS
exhibiting the most rigorous conceptual
development and the most complimentary
format or medium Robin returned to
Hungary recipient of the CCCP thesis
award for architecture nationalism and
internationalism in Indonesia 1959 to
1965 advisor also Felicity Scott for the
thesis making the most significant
contribution to considerations of the
public sphere and which includes a
realized component and don't leave the
stage yet and also for a school-wide
prize for the jisub writing prize for
outstanding paper or thesis on the
history or theory of architecture
written for a class while attending gzip
for his paper on cornering speakers on
political speech in Singapore
okay
chicha whoo recipients of a William
Kinney fellows prize the world of Disney
mapping control apparatuses of
neoliberal dystopia Sara Elizabeth
MacGillivray Yara color Caroline pimento
de Melo Camilla polish players la
recipient of the cccp program award for
highest academic achievement
Gizem sivori recipient of a William
Kinney fellows prize for under the radar
so congratulations for the CCCP class of
Marcus Souter and I are very very proud
of you and now for the master in
architecture and urban design professor
Kate or and professor David smiley for
the word
[Applause]
Majid abdul samad RG feb graduate
currently featured in Columbia News
Jessica Adi we Jaya nisha agarwal Nabi
AG them off nabhi is a recipient of a
Lucille Schmeiser low in fish memorial
prize for outstanding work in the design
studio congratulations
Joon sung on Andreas Benavides ward
andrea is the risk under is the
recipient of the Honor Award for
Excellence in urban design this is the
second height highest award for quality
work in the design studios throughout
the program Maria Isabel Carrasco VIN
Samia
[Applause]
Christopher chiu-wai Kwan Chung Kwan is
the recipient of a GCF visualization
award for innovative use of computing
media in research designs and
fabrications
Bridget
Ivanova cruz treeoche Das Gupta Gabriela
aunt Elyssa Fiorentina sureno Marwa
attest Labib carried Iran who
[Applause]
Lin Chu Wong
Carmelo igneous Colo Carmelo is the
recipient of the highest honor in urban
design for recognition of his
outstanding work in the program this is
the G SAP prize for excellence awkward
Sayeed showed up just say Miriam John
[Applause]
Evelina she nodal Evelina is the
recipient of a load fish memorial prize
for excellence of design - Lee Jung yeah
[Applause]
jean-bob you yeah Hong Yu Jiang in lieu
de ray Liu Mai de indias Mahmoud Mayra
is a recipient of a Williams Kinney
fellows prize for travel and study
abroad for her proposal explorations in
no man's land Amman Jordan
grace Ning sings um
[Applause]
Denis under Denis is a recipient of a
low in fish Memorial Prize for design
yu ting son Dongfang Tong yan hyung
Varys he says
Aneta xerath is a recipient of a low in
fish Memorial Prize for design Khun Jen
[Applause]
Jen Jen
DISA Vedanti Rada
visa is the recipient of a William
Kinney fellows prize for her proposal
rethinking territories of extraction
Kristin Elizabeth Reardon kristin is a
recipient of a low in fish Memorial
Prize for design Rinda Sharma rindas the
recipient of a low in fish prize for
design
[Music]
Jacky son Mario Andres Laura lay on a
leaf mayor on Sal boob one
[Applause]
ciao poo one first yeah whoo Hmong whoo
Shuman whoo Shuman is the recipient of a
low in fish Memorial Prize for design
John yang Zi Yan Yun Chu
[Applause]
we chang-jung how Chen Yong ping in
[Music]
truncheon young good chao-li one
chow-chow You Tube Daniel this
one Poong Jew congratulations to the
2017 class of urban designers and now
for the Master of Science in advanced
architecture design director Enrique
Walker and professor from Harris for the
award the heat noir agem Abu Bakr Hyder
Ali recipient of a willing Kimmy fellows
prize for travel and study abroad for
the proposal artifact the relief and the
arguments Honor Award for high quality
of work in history and theory and design
seminars Adina Ali al-kindi
and Keyshia George
Anto George Vanessa
Marie arugula Jahan bay
kitten bow Jill been recipients of a
low-end fish memorial prize for
outstanding work in the final semester
studio abstract technology customer
studio and recipient of the highest
honor in the ad program the William
where prize for excellence in design so
captain traveling fellowship Karen
Garver Ian Calliope E Karolina guru
yes so john ging chin
cavalry Sarala levity on peonies
Alejandro ciudad katha Franco Giovanni
Kotani recipient of an honor award for
excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studios
they were film crews Yiping
Jen manjong Ruis then do Roach a fun
I'll leave for ludie
now going Nusrat Ghazi
[Applause]
young gong
Eun D go Rui Guan Jonghyun hyung jung-ho
Shang Tzu Chi you a who
[Applause]
Aaron just involve Jun yang Wang Weilin
one
shall you Huang Jingyu a Fung
young-kwang recipient of a William
Kinney fellows price for the proposal
research of the structure space
relationship in work to Vilanova Artigas
Brazil ji Yoon Fung ducting in an eg
chicken
seung-hoon jung yong jim huge in
recipient of an honor award for
excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studio
Colin Robert joy Sara Corrine machmood
bum cue Kim mention Kim Tigran custodian
alexandrine all correct
su-gyeong he Hong Lee Jung Ji Young
[Applause]
Neela moolah wotty Lim chungee Lin
recipient of an honor award for
excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studio
shouldn't we you knife a you Michelle
Karen Lozano recipient of a William can
you fellows price for the proposal
decoding Japan's address system Sooyoung
me
[Applause]
Sacco Bowman gurantee run recipient of a
low-end fish memorial price
architectonic of music advance to the
six Stephen whole studio rwan jabber
mukada Alexandra Plotkin sada Rod Carew
Nia
Ramesh Google Atul khana Matthew
Alexander Anthem
sunaina's Nahal Shah even Charles myth
[Applause]
run song Yi soon destiny Alexis dagger
recipient of a William Kinney fellows
price for the proposal Wonderland
architecture crafting fictional
landscapes to foster creativity and
imagination in phases of learning and an
honor award for excellence in design for
the high quality of work in the time
studio George Benson taunton recipient
of a William Kinney fellows price for
the proposal what do we do after
shopping Mario so tedious the entity Liu
chin utside 1un Leroy tongue Prasanthi
deaky Barossa torn recipients of a
William Kinney fellows price for the
proposal then works ten places young
belgian architect offices
jung-hwan do a one through Asia
won ji-hyun one you young one
Karina sherry right jingxuan whoo
[Applause]
Kyle Jing ha Wu Lin Wu Sunni woof yes a
Wu Shi de room 1 Tong Xu Yi Han Xu
[Applause]
Guinea shoe recipient of the William
Kinney fellows price for the proposal
then works then places young Belgian of
octaves offices and an honour award for
excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studio
Jung soo-jung ciao young ji yi
Yin Yin Yi Ahn in SLV de Japan key
recipient of an honor award for
excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studios
Anthony Lewis sampling recipient of a
William Kieran fellows price for the
proposal artefact of relief
chu Zhang ki young
[Applause]
send young
sure jung-hee you Zhang wen Zhao Zhang
new housing when Mazie Zen way Zhang Chu
Hong's oh then you Joe
Bejo Jana Joe
[Applause]
congratulations ad program class of 2017
and now for the master of architecture
professor hilary sample director
Safiya Abu Almaty Kenneth omoa his he is
the recipient of a William Kenny fellows
prize for travel study abroad for the
proposal 1000 libraries of ancient
manuscripts in Timbuktu and a low
interest and a low in fish memorial
prize for outstanding work in the final
semester Studio images cities circus
modernity and spectacle Mary oh goodness
studio on Drake and Rihanna Barcena
recipients of the penis rise
preservation and legacy reconstructing
the Irving Jae Gil archives William
Edward Vidal
Rebecca ran book the old agree with
Master of Science and urban planning
Kimberly Boone been Jared Street she is
the recipient of a low-end fish frys
infrastructure Jing Louis studio mark
Alden barela's Christopher Michael
brocco Miguel Castaneda killed agree
with Master of Science and real estate
development you James
Jia Yu Chang
the recipient of allowin fish memorial
prize art as social infrastructure
Galia salman else to do diandra Ariela
cohen Elizabeth Leah Cohen Martin
jeweled agree with Master of Science and
urban planning for hey Juan Cornett
he is the recipient of the Building
Technologies Honor Award and the
Campbell Award to celebrate all who
build Columbia University spirit the
University trustees and the board of the
Columbia Alumni Association the CAA
established the Campbell Award presented
by the CAA to a graduating student at
each school who shows exceptional
leadership in Columbia spirit as
exemplified by the late Bill Campbell
chair emeritus University Trustees
outstanding alumnus and CAA co-founder
Jorge served for three years a student
representative appear elected position
that works with senior administration on
issues that concern the student body and
served with diplomacy and true grades
read read read Rodriguez Cruz
Eugene choice with the fan of a Kinney
prize embracing a warmer planet a search
for heat adoption design victor hugo de
souza as Navedo
with the fan of the low-end fish frys
the form of densities Umberto Napolitano
studio for Deng Adel fish vendrick shoot
dude
reza Durrani Clara Celeste de bez
Dijkstra
he is a recipient of the low-end fish
frys rural-urban framework setting the
no meds
John Lin and Josh shovel cofer studio
Jennifer seafang sansheng fey his birth
the fan of a low-end fist cries
psychological correction Juan Herrero
studio Richard Fredrik fudge I sensed
the very gauche Stephanie Elaine
Hamilton is the recipient of a kidney
prize narrative Beyond Borders
Eugene Mandy Han
[Applause]
Amanda Katherine him Benjamin
Alexander Hochberg Michael Stephen
Howard a lq
she is the recipient of a William bikini
fellows prize spaces of the third gender
and the G SAP Service Award in
recognition of willing service to the
school and who gives promise of real
professional merit through attitude and
character and the Avery six award
selected by the MRX students as their
colleagues were questions the standards
of architecture and progress sustained
for professing Stylianos Joanne goat
recipient of the Kinney Prize
visualizing oral histories of the
ma-maybe
Jonathan Alexander Eisen recipient of a
kidney prize conflict urbanism
Mozambique me Sean Chaco Jacob recipient
of a kidney prize social modernism in
Brazil the social dimension of Layla's
architecture also the low end fish fries
monograph studio professors Anatole
son fell marine son Agha Janusz David
you go Kagawa Nicholas Anderson has
nurse T fueled agree with Master of
Science and Historic Preservation
recipient of a kidney prize a
commemorative landscape of the Golan
Heights and Ollie Joe on my list
memorial history theory Honor Award in
recognition of the high-quality work in
the history theory sequence Mustafa
Hassan Khan Khan oops
Kim
jee-in Kwok Troy Matthew Lacombe he is
the recipient of the low-end fish
memorial prize the book of sin loves
Christina go burn a studio and recipient
of the highest honor in my mark program
recipient of the Charles McKim prize for
excellence in design Saul Kaplan
traveling fellowship
stop Valarie listen Jarret lay dual
degrees is a very candidate with Master
of Science in critical curatorial and
conceptual practices Erik pushing Leif
Alex why hello
[Applause]
okay
sorry Melissa
Evette Loyola yes yes okay yeah I don't
know okay okay
Matthew Robert Lauri recipient of the
Kinney Prize hybrid model and collective
architecture Bridget
Kathleen Lucy look low-end fish Memorial
Prize Coppola Hall Stephen Cassell
studio and an honor award for excellence
in design for the high quality of work
in the design studios Andrew Mitchell
Louie recipient of a kidney prize
narratives Beyond Borders and the alpha
Rho Chi medal for ability and leadership
and promise a professional merit
Bernadette MA
dual degree with Master of Science in
real estate development Kevin hall
McNichols mark Madeira dual degree with
Master of Science in real estate
development
grant Edward Duncan McCracken McKinney
Kinney
cries border architecture and urbanism
of mexico's programa national frontiers
Oh Nicolas marksman groans Emily
Elizabeth more recipients of the low-end
fish memorial prize redrawing East
Harlem Hilary sample studio and
recipient of the second highest honor in
the Marc program the AIA Henry Adams
metal nebula Gloria Morales Perez
McKinney prize social modernism in
Brazil the social dimension of Layla's
architecture and an honor award for
excellence in design for the highest
quality of work in the design studios
Harrison Hall Nesbitt recipient of the
low-end fish frys land art national
parks julian rose and garret Riccardi
studio and recipient of the third
highest honor and that mark program the
award for excellence in total design
Michael Gregory Snyder Nickerson skinny
fries kidney fries houses that moved
America's misunderstood vernacular
vehicles for living the low-end fish
fries floating New York Laurie Hawkins
and studio Joni Mizuki boy dine redder
Petterson Julia Ellen Ted KITT Kinney
fries this land is our land the case for
collective ownership along the Rust Belt
and the Avery six award and the Percival
and Noah story
Naomi Goodman prize for the proposal
rebuilding trust collective ownership
and the changing economic
infrastructures of Detroit this prize
enables the recipients to carry out a
project of social significance related
to the interest of Percival Goodman
Brendon William Peterson recipient of
the Keaney prize presence and absence a
hidden Wars persistent impact on Lao
architecture and landscape low-end fish
frys collecting architecture territories
Vietnam and Cambodia mark with judith
studio Britta Isabel Ritter or more
local and melody sue Thomas Lewis Smith
Ileana slden Michael James Storm Kinney
fries faces of the third gender
Curtis Robert stretch skinny fries
Kinney prize the afterlife of Soviet
palaces in Vilnius Lithuania Mong Cheng
Ken
juicy Awang lauren fish fries
redesigning the actor network in
fukushima boy Elmo pajama studio Ren
yuan one draw mine Wang Andrew Joseph
Webber violet Whitney Bruce a fan of the
visualization award for innovative use
of computing media in research design
and fabrication and an honor award for
excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studios
and the Percival and Naomi Goodman prize
men shall we
[Applause]
hey pay yen da yang dual degree with
Master of Science in real estate
development journey on you mung dal
Joong recipient of the kidney prize
architecture of commonality 10 euro Bo
food gemoro and the alternative mode of
contemporary Japan architecture when Jo
recipient recipient of an honor award
for excellence in design for the high
quality of work in the design studio
Salman Jeong recipient of a William
Kinney fellows prize embracing a warmer
planet a search for heat adoption
congratulations to the architecture
students of 2017
and now for the PhD in architecture
director Felicity Scott last but
certainly not least Diana Martinez and
Alexandra Cointreau
some stairs and graduations to both of
you for a really major achievement and
and good luck so this concludes the
ceremony and now the fun thank you
everyone
please join us to celebrate
both in --have mayor and avery temps for
drinks that also don't forget to visit
the end of your show which is sprawling
throughout avery fair weather squirming
or and so just enjoy and congratulations
again
[Applause]
[Music]